I mean it's unbelievable to me to watch
my friends get eighty-three good
comments and one person says they're fat
or they're dumb or it's stupid and they
dwell and they dwell on this and this is
why I keep getting back to this thought
of how do you get insular and know what
you're doing for yourself for yourself
you know Ivan Drago right last seen like
he loses and he's like yeah he's saying
I did this for myself not for the
[ __ ] premier not for the Soviet Union
I was in the ring for myself and it's a
funny scene I was born in Russia
I love the Rocky movies I love America
way more than the Soviet Union so maybe
it sticks with me but there's something
about that scene right everybody knows
Drago for the famous scene like I'll
break you for me it was when he was in
the ring is like for myself
[Music]
what I'm worried about is there's a lot
of people listening right now and saying
okay easy for you guys to say and what I
always tell these kids is you don't
understand that's how we got to that
place you know like everyone's like easy
for you easy for you like I just I'm
just fascinated by people's lack of
patience like I didn't even you know and
I know we live in a social media world
and everybody's getting all these things
flashed at them but it's crazy I'll
never forget the day I started working
full-time in the liquor store which is
22 and I remember saying to myself
literally literally the first day like
I've been working the source for a year
since I was 14 but this is it double
college I actually worked a little few
hours when I drove home from college my
last day but the next day was the first
day it was so weird I hated school my
whole life and I was in like I walked
into the liquor store and I never had to
go to school again it was like crazy it
was the best day in my life
and I'll never forget I remember saying
okay I'm not going to say a word for the
next decade I'm not going to talk to my
friends this is real and I didn't my
high school college friends are very
weirded out by me I like I like just
went in the cocoon and I just worked
every minute and I didn't even think
about popping out until I was 32 not a
word not a peep
not a party nothing and now I've got
kids emailing me like Gary thank you so
much I love your videos you inspire me
when I'm super down I almost gave up
last week you have been doing my new
business for about four months and I hit
a real wall and let's [ __ ] battle
with you for months
yep I even hit a wall you've even gotten
out the gate you you're not even you're
not even in the car you're like still
sleep in your bed I just really want to
push patience and the long game all this
relationship talk you and I had been
doing squirrel bear all that [ __ ] it's a
long long game
you're either playing for life or you're
playing for the few minutes ahead of you
and again this keeps going back over and
over in my mind to what other people
think it's gonna be a good one I see
exactly where I want to do it right here
because the only thing that's holding
you back is you're worried about what
other people have to say you give up on
that [ __ ] and you're clean and you can
go and all of a sudden it's not how much
money you have or how much time you have
you just see that you can do it money
ain't I'm ain't [ __ ] of holding you back
compared to you're worried about other
people's opinions leave that [ __ ] in
high school it's kind of come too many
people right now I mean social media has
become the place where everybody is a PR
agent of themselves let's call it what
it is right I just said there's a bunch
of them here that's the first big
everybody just had not your PR in
yourself I get it you know like I get
people want you know to hook up and have
fun I get everything I get it but it is
creating ungodly short-term behavior
which is not allowing people to really
win the game
[Music]
you know there's a day where you have a
team dinner my team and then another up
yeah on the same day right so maybe we
can play one maybe we can do the my team
dinner because everybody's around and we
can do that
Wednesday yeah something to think about
[Music]
yeah but maybe he can do it so hit him
up Seabees willing to do it that's
number one number two what's the one
what's the Friday in LA in on the 28th
what's that all about but you're not
sure he now
rubs on toast with an e I've never
noticed that before toe it real good man
how you feeling
yep only your threads are hello
really so you go back to the YouTube you
can see where they just started with a
high school suppers gonna be opening and
everything like I just standing out this
cold why don't we leave in here like you
know that dog next door is [ __ ] scary
as [ __ ] I was like time to a call like
you see it crazy scared you were pretty
calm or you knew it was there I was
impressed
[Music]
you know literally you're literally out
of a sitcom
you're literally out of a sitcom you're
like boner from growing beans literally
out of literally out of photography rock
you're being reassigned to BB give me
the best show on you do
[Music]
so crazy not to be in control of where
you go to me that's just crazy
where was I got oh so one of the things
I'm really thinking about is I got to
get to go through this with you guys and
maybe take me another phone year but um
I want to do an off up and the off
season regimen like that's really just
like like real classes real meetings
real just getting kids if they want it
really prepared for life after football
super welcome are you John yeah good to
meet you
Kaylin what's going on how you doing
good mate you know d-roc what's up i
doing sorry man real pleasure
sup gang okay come in smells nice I love
it I love it oh you've got the hockey
bubble you know unstoppable I'm at this
game is it work Oh who wants them Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
I shot
Oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh [ __ ]
haha guys I just sent you some this
calms you down banners calorie and then
took a musket ball right in the chest
so you're just riding around in his
horse - your shipping took a musket ball
survived zoom in nice just want to play
more bubble-hockey none of you could
beat me in bubble-hockey there's not one
person watching this that could beat me
in bubble-hockey nobody from Edmonton or
anywhere else
nice office how long you been in stop
four years
you guys sell a lot of these pedal
catapults yes a member of our signature
fitness product at and then the Marvel
stuff we have these Captain America
plates and Iron Man so you a lot of
Licensing stomach what any coconut based
beverage we have a recover coconut water
with a little bit of salt density well
let's do it you know thank you
I got comes out erock you always doing
your thing I'm proud of you yeah thank
you
you get out you take the empty key John
you're so pumped right now
you love stuff you love shopping I know
but the way you look at stuff I don't
even notice I don't even notice stuff
you're like you really get in the zone
Thank You Man
real pleasure to meet you everything you
do sir thank you very the past since I
moved to Austin number and uh very
prompt Connecticut nice what are you
doing down here
I'm a filmmaker good for you yeah so I'm
just uh trying to plug away to write a
actually starting up a media marketing
proposed Capri also in the getting a
deja
everything that I can Sasa man real
pleasure to meet you at the NFA some
kind of weird effort right
maybe that's amazing kid can play you
can play none of my stuff is predicated
on things that go away like I become
more like guru as I get older you know
like businessman never goes out of style
it's so great like when you grow up you
want to be an athlete until you realize
like that games over when you're 30 you
know everybody wants to get in it right
like everybody wants to make money
taking a picture with a product yeah you
know like for you it's just going to
bring on more competition but like
you're better you're better that's it
that's where people could use like I
remember people back in the day said to
me Gary it's socially to get big aren't
going to be a lot of people are going to
try to be you of that I'm like yeah it's
like everything else it's like it's like
asset
it's like athlete right like if you're
the best in the world like you're the
best for world but it's hard to maintain
like fresh after you win a championship
like the next year you might might just
not be hungry enough I always wonder
about like when I'm in my most prime of
my business clear like that will be
captured forever that's like that I'll
be like this great deal I did like
nobody was there when I was like oh I'm
an invest in Twitter there's no like
it's not like a last you know what I
mean there's you don't have that but
pros and cons I would say I mean
entrepreneurship is getting so crazy
like it's so crazy to me how much Fame
an entrepreneur can achieve now that's
been weird and fun and interesting and
there becomes like scratch the itch of
difference whatever happen right you
never said out like what ever ever ever
ever a lot of cute oh you know I think I
think a lot about that
that one up regret is poison regret is
poison I tell every kid I was like just
get it it's like give it and so you can
just feel good at a hundred know what I
feel good about all right I maybe was
awfully 1,600 I maybe wasn't 1,600 in us
good 3,000 us with it you know what's so
funny so we were just talking about
entrepreneurship
yeah I've been tell a lot of kids so I
have a lot of 15 year olds who follow me
on Instagram and I tell them on VM or
when they hit me up I'm like if you're
going fast then I really literally use
that analogy I'm like I use basketball
sometimes conceive a smaller number I'm
like you're not one of the 500 best
players in the world you're making
$30,000 doing what you want in your to
600 best in the world at if you're the
600 or 3,000 specced entrepreneur in the
world there were hundreds of millions of
dollars of planet it's been beautiful
wrapping with you son man I'm looking
forward to a lot of cool things we got
creative futures I can't wait which
everybody could help say I much love
beautiful that was fun yeah man yelling
at people
oh yeah five $10,000 books because to me
yeah to me I think that is forever right
like my four-year-old son is a Nerdist
why it happened my four-year-old son
Xander is like all about it he doesn't
give a [ __ ] about ken griffey jr. or Cal
Ripken right like I'm so thankful that's
like I just wish people could be
grateful work
looks like Shaq looks like Shaq got came
Shaq came through ass off the loading
dock I've done I mean this is at home
now then he's Wine Library for me yeah
you know sup guys
now do you guys to all
direct-to-consumer know we're about 90
percent though that's cool yeah
we got relegated to this by 400 trillion
to one when you understand that math how
can't you live your life that's how rare
it is to be a human being please squeeze
the [ __ ] out of your one life
I'm like pom
[ __ ] because the only thing that's
keeping you back is the other people
that are judging you and who gives a
[ __ ] about them awesome [ __ ]
I just manifest honestly I swear to god
this little pisses me off I really wish
that I could rap because that's the
thing it is but I still can't how was it
Oh a lot of flexibility all that stuff
better man because it so good yeah nice
to meet you yeah good luck to you my man
real pleasure sir yeah good to see you
again man wonders thankfully very one
lever it is
thank you brother I really appreciate
that real appreciative Thank You Man
thank you so much my brother man I'll
see you soon
I'll come through again alright we're
doing what's going on
can you just have leverage and not I'm
not crippled by like is that where I'm
headed or different I just bring value
get a lot of attention and then you can
always trade out of the relationship
understand 100% never get ahead of
yourself get out real pleasure man hey
careful
hi my fantasy real pleasure yeah I will
I will
let me let me let me throw something at
you I'd love to get you guys reaction
it's like to think about like so I think
what a lot of people are doing well
right now that I care about and what I
care about what I'm doing is we're
hacking culture right like your
penetrating attention so to me it's the
kind of thing that like business leaders
and fifteen-year-old girls would both go
to like I'm that's where I'm going with
the high/low right like
right and that's right that's it I mean
look
[Music]
guess what I lived that world I was part
of the early phase of this right I
started YouTube show more months after
YouTube came out there was nobody there
like there was no social media there was
myspace but if you remember people went
to your wall right it was a different
week so yeah man I just had like one
comment like weird
you know like like like there was you
know and now what's happening is not
only are we addicted to the feedback but
we're crippled I mean it's unbelievable
to me to watch my friends get 83 good
comments and one person says they're fat
or they're dumb or stupid and they dwell
and they dwell on this and this is why I
keep getting back to this thought of how
do you get insular and know what you're
doing
for yourself for yourself you know Ivan
Drago right last seen like he wheezes
and he's like yeah he's saying I do this
for myself not for the [ __ ] premiere
not for the Soviet Union I was in the
ring for myself and it's a funny scene I
was born in Russia
I love the Rocky movies I love America
way more than the Soviet Union so maybe
it sticks with me but there's something
about that scene right everybody knows
Drago for the famous scene like I'll
break you for me it was when he was in
the ring is like to myself
[Music]
11 p.m. Texas time midnight back home in
a long day getaway in a 3 a.m. and
started back up at 8:00 that's if you
ask us if you ever and that's how I feel
like I just don't give a [ __ ] what
anybody thinks
and I mean not my kids not my parents
not my wife now I equally care so much
of how they view me and what they think
of me it's pulling from opposite
directions but you got to start with
yourself because when you're actually
allowing other people to get in you're
vulnerable
[Music]